c'est parce que vous êtes un set
dépersonnaliser que vous êtes un grand
comédien c'est parce que vous n'existez
pas oui si vous existiez mais moi je
préfére est pernoud jeu présentateur de
13h régionales je vois prompteur qu'est
ce qu'on a sur le midi palavas bon tu
vas chez la platé crime très jolie
lettre quand j'ai fait une anomalie
pernaut qui est un moment important dans
mon existence c'est que pour moi le jour
j'ai rencontré le 13 heures le régional
j'ai vu un grand j'ai vu un homme normal
tout va je pense que si on mettait un
électro de bonheur entre pernaut le
présentateur du 13 heures que j'aime
beaucoup et mon truc si on pouvait nous
coller quelque chose sur la table ou sur
l'oeuvre sur les cuisses et qu'on dise
d'autres bonheurs 12 par exemple sur
pernod ça doit aussi les 8 9 12 14 16
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
fun 12 13 mai ça dure une heure quarante
cinq par jour
tout le reste du temps je pense que la
vie de pernod d'ailleurs l'avis de
pernod pardonnez moi ça vous intéresse
mais permet nous sommes pas devant un
porno perdre ça nous intéresse dans une
chose très simple c'est que il m'a dit
c'est hallucinant parce que comment se
fait-il que vous savez comment je rentre
chez moi parce que j'avais parlé qu'en
le voyant au trésor je visualise et ça
rentrait chez lui tu vas avec la voiture
je fasse ça fera une peugeot way ou une
renault et puis que sa femme était en
train de finir
et puis quelle il arrivait pernaut qui
faisait chéri kg est un peu de buch
tu vois ce que je dirai la femme dit oh
merde c'est très bien je m'occupe jamais
allé j'y mets à laraque et ça c'est un
enthousiasme vis palou nouveau
spinosaure même nietzsche à il faut
quand même le pape dépressif pour entrer
après le boulot et dire à sa femme je
fais un peu de buts et la femme fait que
j'aurais même les entrées ou ingérée
c'était drôlement les médias qui met la
bûche et puis après il fait mr je vais
garder la bannière il va garer la
bagnole y revient ça c'est un être qui
va bien il a pas les spinoza
il n'a pas lu ni jean vit totalement
pernaut j'en fais pas un cheval de
bataille médiatique
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu